l'action de l'Iran a choqué le
monde civilisé l'ambassade a été saisie
et plus de 60 citoyens américains
doivent être retenus en otages nous devons y aller maintenant
ce qui s'est passé six otages sont sortis par une
sortie arrière où sont-ils la
maison de l'ambassadeur du Canada a des
gardiens de la révolution  porte à porte ces gens
meurent ils meurent mal ce que nous aimons pour cela
nos vélos ou vous pouvez simplement envoyer une
formation nous les rencontrons aussi à la frontière
avec Gatorade il va falloir un miracle
pour les faire sortir j'ai une idée qu'ils sont  une
équipe de tournage canadienne pour un film de science-
fiction Je vole vers Téhéran nous
volons tous ensemble en tant qu'équipe de tournage J'ai besoin de
toi pour m'aider à faire un faux film eh bien
tu veux venir à Hollywood agir comme un
grand coup sans rien faire
ouais toi  'll fit right in need a script
Fargo science fantasy aventure low
estate Mars desert ils ont besoin d'un
endroit exotique pour tourner tu dois la
produire si je fais un faux film ça va
être un faux hit tu n'as pas de meilleur
mauvais  idée que celle-ci c'est la meilleure mauvaise
idée que nous ayons monsieur de loin
vous avez 72 heures pour obtenir la souris
ils reçoivent un visiteur vous avez fait sortir les
gens de cette façon avant non vous
nous demandez de vous faire confiance avec nos
vies c'est quoi  Je le fais et je ne l'ai jamais laissé en
moi dessus Je sais qu'ils le sont et ils savent
qu'ils se cachent c'est fini de venir ils
restent ici ils seront probablement
pas pris beaucoup nous sommes responsables de ces
gens
je suis responsable du
temps  pour t'aller